تحديات العام الجديد 20- 23
الاقتصاديه تحديدا محور دائم للتحليل
والشد والجذب خصوصا بعد عام من الاحداث
السلبيه منها ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وازمه
الطاقه والغذاء وكاله بلومبرج نشرت تقريرا
حمل خمسه سيناريوهات تنذر بمخاطر اقتصاديه
متوقعه استمرار ارتفاع تضخم باعتباره احد
المخاطر الرئيسي ل 20 23 بينما لا يزال
مستقبل رائحه كورونا لا يزال مبهما مع
المخاوف من ظهوره متحولات جديده خاصه في
الصين حاليا اولى هذه السيناريوهات الخمسه
بطبيعه الحال باستمرار التضخم في هذا
الصدد الى هبوط اكثر للاسهم والسندات
زياده قوه الدولار مع ارتفاع تكاليف
الاقتراض ما يهدد بحدوث ركود
السيناريو الثاني الخوف من تعثر الصين
فرغما ان الاسهم الصينيه قفزت بنحو 35
بالمئه مع اتجاه الصين لانهاء عمليات
الاغلاق لكن هذه المكاسب مهدده بسبب مخاطر
ارهاق النظام الصحي والسبب تفشي العدوى
ولا يزال الانتعاش في الاسهم الصينيهالشا
واي احتمال لتعثر النشاط الاقتصادي من
شانه ان يضعف الطلب في اسواق السلع
الاساسيه خصوصا بالنسبه للمعادن الصناعيه
الحديث
السيناريو الثالث
القاتل استمرار حرب اوكرانيه مع تداعياتها
على الاقتصاد العالمي كل وازمه الطاقه كما
ان استمرار العقوبات على روسيا وداعمها قد
تؤدي الى تقليل المعروض في العالم فيما
يتعلق بالغذاء والطاقه اخرى مثل الاسمده
وبعض المعادن والكيماويات والسيناريو
الاكثر رعبا هو استخدام روسيا السلاح
النووي في اوكرانيا فمن شان ذلك انهاء
الصادرات الزراعيه الاوكرانيه بضربه واحده
لخامس اكبر مصدر للحبوب في العالم
السيناريو الرابع هو تراجع الاسواق
الناشئه يحذر التقرير من ان اي فشل في كبح
جناح التضخم من شانها ان يؤثر سلبا في
الاسواق الناشئه التي قد تعاني في 20 23
اذا استمر الدولار في الارتفاع لان العديد
من البلدان الاسواق الناشئه لديها ديون
مقاومه بالدولار السيناريو الاخير عوده
الجائحه تكثر التحذيرات مؤخرا من ان ظهور
جديده اكثر عدوى لكوفيد نايتين او حتى
المتغيرات الحاليه التي تستمر لفتره اطول
قد يؤدي الى تعطيل سلاسل التوريد مره اخرى
وبالتالي قد يؤدي الى زياده التضخم والى
تباطؤ النشاط الاقتصاديه